so it's this idea of like is a
journalist just like a megaphone you
know Legacy Media Outlets by and large
were all on board with a certain
narrative people needed a place like
Twitter where they could be exposed to
different ideas where some of those
ideas completely nuts yes but many of
those ideas were absolutely legitimate
this is a place for legitimate debate by
people who understand the issues those
views were suppressed in many instances
that is very troubling there was a trump
tweet about how he said something like
don't be afraid anymore it was something
to that effect does this go against our
our guidelines shouldn't we be like you
know labeling this as misleading or take
it down and some of the other Executives
had to write back and say
um optimism is not against our policy
my God this like super high level person
actually even entertained the idea for
something like that to be super the rest
of that alone was was like kind of
astonishing it was just a bizarre
experience that I will never get over
like it's permanently altered me
foreign
[Music]
ometry on the road from the USA I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is an
author and journalist David Spike
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me and it's a real pleasure
before we get cracking uh tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
it All Began on the subway or that was
the last leg of the journey yeah um I'm
a writer I write books I write news
articles investigative pieces commentary
so I've been doing that for a number of
years
um written a few books before that I was
playing music for a number of years uh
the joke I like to tell people is well
it wasn't a joke this was real that
after I'd been trying to succeed as a
musician for many years I went home and
I said Mom Dad you know this is very
hard of them having a kid who's you know
trying to do that and I said look I'm no
longer trying to make it as a rock star
tour and they said huh thank God I said
instead I'm going to be writing a novel
so I choose uh uh uneasy paths I guess
but finally it seems to have been
working out uh so I've kind of hit my
stride I think in the last decade
um working in non-fiction and doing what
I'm doing and here I am I guess chatting
with you guys yeah and one of the things
we really wanted to talk to you about is
is the Twitter files and to see I still
don't know what I think about it because
on the one hand I was one of the people
who was like super excited about uh
seeing you know lifting the curtain so
to speak but I also felt that when we
did we kind of normally really saw what
we already knew and so it was kind of
pre-discounted now I'm not saying that's
accurate but that was my impression
so what is it about the Twitter files
that people should actually think oh
that was worthwhile you know all this
hype and all the rest of it yeah it's a
good question I
I I can only speak about my own
reporting or at least I I can only speak
tell us about the experience first of
all what was it like going in there and
you know how did it work yeah so
um I was brought out there by Barry
Weiss who um as most people probably
know Elon Musk gave access to Matt taibi
initially I think he was the first one
and then some short period of time after
that he gave Barry access Barry runs
basically a media Empire
I'm just a small piece of the Empire I
guess and um and I had sent an email to
Barry and and one or two of her editors
who I knew um because I had written for
them before and I said because I've been
writing about covid stuff for since the
beginning of the pandemic I I didn't
know what they were doing if they were
going back I didn't know anything I just
said just trying to be helpful look if
you guys are going to
um be sending someone else back there
whatever if you're going back yourself
these are the things I might look for
and I was kind of sheepish actually like
I thought it was a little maybe
presumptuous to me to I'm like who am I
to tell them but I was just these are a
few things I would do and like an hour
later I get an email back can you get on
a plane to San Francisco I was like okay
so they you know they figured you know I
guess based on that and everything that
they know about me that I should be the
one to go out and at least initially
look into
um stuff related to covid because I
think up to that point the reporting
wasn't specific to the pandemic it was
on a variety of other things Hunter
Biden laptop and other stuff so I went
out there really the sort of
um I don't know if this is the right
word but the specialist on like this is
the one lane that I'm gonna travel in
which is related to covid
um and so I was there it was only a few
days while I was there Michael Sheldon
Burger was there Layton Woodhouse Lee
Fong
um so it was um the three of them and me
and um each of us working on our own
things but everyone was helping each
other as well
um just because it was so challenging to
look through the material and
um and that's it I basically I mean I
could get into a little bit of details
about what the process you're nodding
like yes please do
um yeah because I think they're I I
think there's still a fair amount of
misunderstanding or confusion about what
the process was people like why didn't
you do this or you should have done that
I think what a lot of people don't know
or realize is
some I don't know company or some Law
Firm where they're like open up the
books and you can you know just rifle
through there are very specific ways
that we were able to search there were
no restrictions on what we could look up
or or publish
um that's important to note but the
process of actually searching was really
challenging this was not like what we're
used to as regular citizens like
Googling something or whatever the the
systems in place to actually do the
digging were
um we're not very user friendly so I
would break it down into there's
basically two separate paths that we
could search now one was looking at what
I would call like the log files of
individual accounts
um and there was an engineer in the room
with us on a special laptop and we could
give them someone's name and say I would
like to look up this person's account we
were not able to see any like private
information on anyone's account which is
important for me to note because there
were tons of lawyers involved in this
but what we were able to see were on
someone's account their activity and
what Twitter internally had if there
were any Flags or marks on certain
things on the account as a whole or on
certain tweaks and then there were tons
of kind of files within files within
files
um so that was one thing to search and
then the other one was looking up on
internal Communications or internal and
external through email or through slack
channels and so the way that those
searches were not performed in the room
we had to basically send them an email
to the people I don't know if they were
like next door to us or what but they
were it wasn't directly in there and
then sometime later a person would come
in with a different laptop and say
Here's this stuff you can look at this
now so if you imagine we're looking and
we had to look up specific employees you
couldn't just say I want to find
anything on myocarditis no you had to
give and I'm not sure the reasoning
behind this but you had to pick certain
employees and they could look up that
employee's emails and we could say I
want to see all the emails from this
person from this date to this date and
then so we could get 4 000 emails from
someone if you're like so and I have you
know X number of hours and one to look
at this stuff so it's it's very
challenging it's more it's not just like
oh let's just do a word search and we're
done
um although that was part of it so
you're trying to sift through all this
stuff to find what you're looking for
sometimes I had a specific idea most of
the time I knew what I was looking for
and I was just seeing if it was there or
not there and other times you don't even
know what you're looking for it's just
like I know this is an important person
I know this particular topic is
something that we might have a reason to
believe something happened let's see
what's there if something's interesting
or not interesting or newsworthy or not
newsworthy and that was so it was very
laborious very tedious to do these types
of searches the stuff on the log files I
mean it could take a very long time to
like dig through and you find a
particular tweet and then and then
through there there's all sorts of code
and different stuff written there and
then the engineer was basically
explaining to okay here we go I can see
this tweet what's labeled on here
um or not labeled does that make sense
how I'm describing it okay very much so
okay and I was going towards so what
role did Elon have in this was he
overseeing it did you have to report to
him did you have to say look this is
what we found how involved was he in
this entire investigation I love the way
you call them Elon buddy
well look I'm being professional between
me and him it's Muskie
yeah I mean again at least for my my
experience
um I had no personal interaction with
with musk at all
um my understanding is and this is
through talking with Barry it was that
um he we had on we had access to
whatever we wanted there were no
restrictions and
um the only uh sort of rule was whatever
we found we had to publish it on Twitter
first and you know and it didn't need to
be far in advance but it could be five
minutes but it just needed to go on to
Twitter first other than that it wasn't
if you find X Y or Z you're not allowed
to do this et cetera and as far as I'm
aware unless there was some incredible
conspiracy happening
um there was similarly there was no
um constraints placed on us to get the
information so both in regards to what
we were able to look for and then what
we found neither of those had any
restrictions on them whatsoever you know
this engineer is I'm literally looking
over the person's shoulder as they're
doing the searches I cannot imagine how
that could have been in some way
compromised without us knowing it's some
other guy had interviewed me and he kept
saying well maybe the email searches or
the other thing they were filtering it
and again we're talking about thousands
of emails I I can't imagine how they
could possibly have done this and it
took us a team of four people in real
time looking so I don't see because they
didn't know what we were going to be
searching for so this all was happening
in real time it was very kind of like by
this to your pants just trying to do it
I saw Elon while we were there but there
was no he did not interact with me or
have any involvement as far as what I
was looking for and what I was able to
publish and that been the case what do
with your findings what was the thing
that shocked you the most what was the
thing that surprised you
hmm
I would I think looking at some of the
prior reporting
um
I think maybe I had a little bit more of
uh an assumption about the staff you
know this guy Joel Roth and some other
people and I have to say
um many many instances as I'm reading
through these internal slack
Communications and in emails in many
instances
these people at Twitter really were
trying their best to
moderate content in a way that they
thought was reasonable now I think they
were wrong in how they performed this
but I but there's that you know there's
this is kind of a harsh expression but
you know what's the thing about don't
ascribe to to you know nefariousness
what can be you know actually is just
sort of stupidity or something not
saying that they were stupid but in the
sense that I don't think this was some
big plot that the these people genuinely
were trying to sift out things that they
believed were harmful I think they were
completely out of their depth with what
they were doing and I think structurally
this was totally inappropriate about how
they handled a whole variety of things
if so
versus like on an individual level I saw
a lot of people with a lot of
conversations pushing back against what
they perceived the government wanted
pushing back against what other
co-workers wanted in too many instances
bad choices were made but it is not like
there was this thing constantly all the
time where they were just you know
taking out the red pen against all sorts
of tweets that they didn't like
um there was an internal debate that
happened oftentimes and I reported on on
a few of them one of them that was
actually kind of both encouraging in the
end result but also revealing in the
same way about how problematic it was
um Jim I forget the guy's name but one
of the the lead Attorneys at Twitter
there was a trump tweet about how he
said something like don't be afraid
anymore it was something to that effect
and he was emailing people internally
saying does this go against our our
guidelines shouldn't we be like you know
labeling this as as misleading or take
it down and some of the other Executives
have to write back and say
optimism is not against our policy so it
was both like good that there was that
stop Gap but also like my God this like
super high level person actually even
entertained the idea for something like
that to be suppressed that alone was was
like kind of astonishing well that is
astonishing and uh also I mean I think
if you remember and most people want to
forget that period of time because if
you know it was a bit not a bit it was
very unpleasant for a lot of people and
for a lot of people it's traumatic one
of the things I think a lot of people
particularly those of us who felt the
both government and big Tech became
quite authoritarian during the pandemic
was this feeling that
we're not actually able to have a proper
sensible discussion about something that
actually really matters
to what extent do you feel based on what
you saw
our ability to genuinely discuss one of
the most important issues in our
lifetimes actually for a lot of people
was curtailed by what they ended up
doing in Twitter whether it was
maliciously motivated or whether it was
incompetence or stupidity or they just
thought that's the right way to do it
how much of what happened was wrong I
guess is what I'm asking you
um it's impossible to quantify because I
I didn't do some sort of systematic you
know analysis
um but I would characterize it to my
mind it was profoundly wrong about what
happened at least in the things that I
researched related give us a breakdown
like what are those things okay so
profoundly wrong right so
the thing about Twitter is I think a lot
of us had hoped or saw it social media
in general as an alternative to sort of
I guess what's called the mainstream
media Legacy Media this is another pla
this is a venue for people who are shut
out of these other
um platforms that they can use their
voice and by when I say people it
doesn't just mean regular people I'm
talking about highly credentialed
experts who just had views that were you
know oppositional to what the
establishment wanted
um and so what I observed throughout the
pandemic and then what I was able to
basically prove
um was there was a there was a
systematic suppression of
content that went against the
establishment narrative at least in
America about what was considered
appropriate and what was considered
correct
um and anything oftentimes that went
against that was labeled as misleading
um tweets were taken down and the counts
were suspended on numerous occasions so
what I don't know is the extent of that
because again that would require some
sort of analysis that that you know an
individual reporter is not capable of
doing but what we do know is I observed
it as a person deep in this for years
and what and what I wanted to do was
kind of deconstruct
um well how did this happen I you know
because so many times I would see a
tweet by someone like Martin coldor
who's this prominent um
infectious disease epidemiologist who
was at Harvard Medical School and I
would see stuff by him being labeled as
misleading I'm like that's troubling
what's going on so man when I got to go
to Twitter I'm like I can try to find
out well how did that happen what led to
that so I sort of wanted to work
backwards to find out because I was
baffled I'm like what the hell is going
on so what did you find so what I found
I I view it as sort of like three
different like buckets about how they
did this there there were there was a
system of bots that they set up this
sort of like AI system where I I guess
they crawl through Twitter and they're
trained whether it's through certain
keywords or other mechanisms they're
trained to look for certain tweets that
were problematic that the system the
algorithm viewed as problematic so some
of the tweets that were perfectly
legitimate perfectly appropriate were
caught up in this this bot system
um if you think of like a a trawling net
in the ocean you're looking for a
certain type of fish but inevitably
you're you're going to catch some
dolphins in there and I think this bot
system probably did catch a lot of garb
garbage you know some crazy you know
conspiratorial Q Anon you know microchip
type of stuff but in that process they
caught a hell of a lot of dolphins in
that net too
um so one thing were these Bots the
other thing you had these independent
contractors in places like Philippines
who were basically deciding the content
whether something is misleading or not
they were given these decision trees
basically this kind of thing where you
would have a drop down menu maybe you
see a tweet that has myocarditis in it
maybe a bot would first flag the Tweet
then it gets sent to this independent
contractor and they're like myocarditis
click then there's a drop down menu good
or bad click and then you know and it
would be this system set up but the idea
that some random guy sitting in a cube
Farm in the Philippines is going to
adjudicate something as complex as
whether or not a tweet about myocarditis
is misleading or not is insane like of
course they're not going to be able to
do that so you had that and then the
third mechanism were people themselves
at Twitter and there are many instances
were either a particular tweet or
account would be escalated where people
were looking at it or sometimes they
were just intervening like that example
about the Trump tweet so you had real
people doing this in in Twitter you know
at high levels um you had these
independent contracts tractors and then
you have this algorithm so between those
three systems that's how things were
flagged and what and you know we had
tweets by people who were Physicians who
were you know licensed medical doctors
who were tweeting things from
studies that were published in peer
review journals now does it mean the
study is is well done I don't know but
it's in a peer-reviewed journal
certainly not for Twitter to decide that
something that's published is not and
nevertheless they were flagged and in
every instance these were things that
only went in One Direction there never
seemed to be something that was too Pro
lockdown Pro vaccine that would never be
flagged as far as I saw but anything
that questioned that that is met by by
you know pulled up in the net
um and that so there were many instances
where things that were true or that were
legitimate from published sources that
were uh tweeted by
um credentialed people that were
nevertheless flagged and that to me is
just like so profoundly disturbing when
you think about the information
environment and like what we perceive to
be real or not real what information
we're all getting and for someone like
me who I was knowledgeable about this
stuff it was frustrating and in race
aging but what I'm more worried about
are you know regular people who have
normal jobs they're not following the
stuff closely and they see misleading
tweet you know like a label put on it I
mean that's obviously going to have an
incredible amount of influence over the
public conversation and the narrative
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russia men who clean up executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant Crump reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this off is legit and
we'll have you smelling like royalty but
a good kind not prince Andrew get 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com that's 20 up and free
shipping with the code trigger 20 at
manscape.com it's time to throw out all
your old hygiene habits and upgrade your
life
isn't the real problem here I mean to me
there's two real problems and I'll come
to that the second question in a moment
but to me this is the problem when you
politicize issues which have no basis in
politics whatsoever this is a virus
released from a Chinese Laboratory
he's saying or deleted but there isn't
the problem when we politicize issues
like this and this is what happens
well yeah it's politicized and it's also
at least related you know to covid
specifically there was this default that
the C whatever the CVC says we're gonna
go with them and on one level I
appreciate that I I get it it's like am
I gonna believe some random you know
doctor or some random not even doctor
some random person or am I gonna trust
the CDC so on one level I get that but
that's not how Free Speech works and by
the way the experts are wrong all the
time right and the CDC or nor a
government remember the leader of uh New
Zealand I think at one point she said I
am the truth maybe she didn't say that
but like the government we are your
wonderful single Source yeah remember
that unless you hear it from us
um it is not the truth dismiss anything
else we will continue to be your single
source of Truth we will provide
information frequently
that is insane that's horrible for any
democracy for anyone so I think you know
it's the you know these are cliches but
sunlight is the best disinfectant like
let the best ideas win out sometimes
there will be bad ideas but what I think
this showed was that our government
has no confidence
in regular people being able to be
informed there's in this like incredible
sort of like paternalistic attitude of
like the masses are stupid
and they cannot be trusted so what I
think ultimately happened was this idea
of the noble lie where over and over
there would be these uh infectious
disease experts and others within the
government where they were saying
something whether it was about vaccines
whether it's about Mass where they were
kind of often just gilding the Lily
there may have been the underlying truth
but then they would pushed over the edge
because they felt like they had to
encourage people to quote do the right
thing and so and I think Twitter most of
the people who work there I don't know
now after The Exodus when Elon took over
but they were almost all of them were
left leaning
um and they were you know aligning
themselves with the Biden Administration
which was aligned with the CDC so there
was this structural I you know um bias
toward a certain truth but again I mean
there are plenty of differences of
opinion from experts around the world on
a lot of these ideas and where different
countries were doing things differently
and within America the idea that you're
not supposed to listen to
um the opinion of a doctor at Harvard
Medical School or someone at Stanford or
anyone for that matter you have to I
don't think
for obviously anyone should be able to
say whatever they want in a country that
values Free Speech but as far as a
platform like Twitter I I don't think
there should be zero constraint because
I think it will create an environment
where there's just tons of like violence
and pornography and stuff that most
people probably don't want to be
bombarded with that constantly so it's
not that there's no line but I think the
line should be Far Far Over toward
leniency toward like a wide latitude
um and they were far far too tight on
how they were
um controlling and policing information
and it's profoundly wrong that they did
that and as I said you know it just it
it altered the information environment
and because you know Legacy Media
Outlets by and large were all on board
with a certain narrative
um it was people needed a place like
Twitter where they could be exposed to
different ideas were some of those ideas
completely nuts yes but many of those
ideas were absolutely legitimate this is
a place for legitimate debate by people
who understand the issues and
nevertheless those views were suppressed
in many instances that is very troubling
David oh sorry France yeah I was going
to say I have actually a great deal of
empathy for big Tech and I can already
see the comments how can you say
but it's true because just imagine
you're a cuckman yeah exactly anyway in
the words of my ex-girlfriend now
um
but just put yourself in their shoes so
you've got this pandemic no one knows
what the mortality rate is we're seeing
these images come from places like Italy
where they look absolutely horrific
and then you have this incredibly
powerful tool at your fingertips which I
think it's fair to say no one
understands how powerful this thing is
all the long terms implications of this
technology
and you have to figure it out as you go
along through the pandemic isn't it
natural that you would urge towards the
side of caution when dealing with this
particular matter because I would
certainly do that
yeah I mean I think as you know as I
started out saying I I I felt a lot of
sympathy toward what these people were
doing and I think they were trying their
best I think you know one of the things
about
society and institutions is that ideally
structures are put in place to help
protect us from ourselves Your Instinct
sounds like a reasonable and natural one
let's try to be cautious with like let's
try to okay the CDC says X Y or Z let's
stick with that if someone's saying ABC
different from the X then maybe we
should you know I the instinct is there
and it comes from a good place I think
some people but there needs to be a
structure in place to go against that
instinct because that instinct is wrong
oftentimes and you know there's just so
many instances in
Society for you know all of history
where the experts think one thing and
they were wrong right and if anything
something like a pandemic it it we went
in the opposite direction of where we
should have gone we should have the
public I really and and I'm writing a
book about the pandemic specifically
about American schools and what happened
with them during the pandemic but
because that's part of the larger thing
I spend a lot of time I'm looking at in
sort of like a more panoramic view and
to me everything comes back to the
public health authorities and that they
created an environment where so a place
like Twitter
um felt like they had to go with them
because they spoke with an unearned
certainty about so many things and as we
saw over and over again those things got
walked back from the masking guidance
flip-flop to vaccines we were told they
would do one thing and then they did
something else
and the excuse of well the science
changed sometimes that was true and
sometimes it wasn't but the point isn't
that you you can't change your advice or
Guidance the point was that when they
initially gave the guidance when they
initially told people about these things
this was said with a strong degree of
certainty yes and it was not only was it
politicized but it was moralized
how you guys doing with vaccines
oh you should get it first okay that way
you won't give it to them I thought I
thought I would give it to them if I get
it no no not at all in fact we got to
get you vaccinated so that if you were
to get infected you could pass it on to
them so you're actually protecting your
family by getting him vaccinated well I
heard that it doesn't
um cure it and it doesn't
um stop you from getting it no so on the
very very very rare chance that you do
get it even if you're vaccinated it's a
very you don't even feel sick it's like
you don't even know you got infected
it's very very good at protecting you oh
my God they're going to keep the
outbreak smoldering in the country it's
so crazy I mean they're not doing it
because they say they don't want to do
it they're Republicans they don't like
to be told what to do and we've got to
break that you know unpack that I'm not
going to be lining up taking a shot on a
vaccination for something that wasn't
clear in the first place and then you
all create a shot in miraculous time
nine months is definitely not enough for
nobody to be taking no vaccination that
you all came up with the only reason I'm
talking to you right now as close as we
are is that I've been vaccinated right
but if it allow thousands of people like
you don't get vaccinated you're going to
let this virus continue to percolate in
this country and in this world something
like the common flu then right you gonna
pass yeah definitely because when you
start talking about paying people to get
vaccinated when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated it's something else going on
with that something something else going
on it is something going on you're right
but I'm glad millions of people like me
and most everybody here didn't get into
you know what their incentive was
protecting their health and protecting
the city
it's okay our campaign is about fear
it's about inciting fearing people you
all attack people with fear that's what
this pandemic is it's a fear it's fear
this pandemic
it was moralized that you were a piece
of if you did not do what they said
if you didn't wear a mask you were a
right-wing and well the evidence
on that has been pretty iffy for a long
time about Mass mandates the evidence on
a whole variety of things on school
closures and all these other things are
actually not clear in the slightest bit
I'm spending you know a thousand page
book showing that it wasn't the way they
said because it comes back to that well
yes I but I guess the reason we're
asking you this question David is I
think we are all in a position where
we're trying to understand what the true
impact of this new social media
technology is on the world and one of
the things that it has done it is
shared consensus of reality completely
and the other thing is it puts into
question you know the two of us and I'm
sure you as well really feel the free
speech is a crucial part of What Not
only is you know you could say the first
amendment in America but it's not about
that it's about the fact that the entire
Western project is based on the
principle that people are allowed to
express themselves
and at the same time I have to recognize
you know we run a YouTube channel which
has you know half a million subscribers
on YouTube and probably the same on the
podcast if we thought that you know the
comments on our YouTube videos had the
potential to kill 10 000 people we would
think about what we do differently right
even if our impression of that was wrong
and I think we're all in the place now
where the pandemic was really the first
major test case of what we now think
we're supposed to do about the fact that
we have communication technology that
allows one person to some would argue
not an inside Ariah or start you know we
had David Ike in the UK who was talking
about how covert is caused by 5G and
then the next day people are burning
down telephone Master right so
that I think is is probably where the
good intentions of the people that
you're talking about were but at the
same time like once you start censoring
Nobel prize winning scientists who are
talking about their field of expertise
that's you know way too far exactly
right so my point is the the line is
somewhere in between and nobody knows
exactly where it should be do they
that's my view on it um the only thing
that I do know for certain is the line
was drawn far far too close towards
censorship and I think while it
shouldn't be no line at all that we're
agreeing on and you know something is
clearly inciting violence if something
you know in these types of circumstances
but by and large we need to let ideas be
free we need to let people communicate
and
um again when you have credentialed
people but we shouldn't only say
credentialed experts there's plenty of
people who didn't have credentials who
are also correct on a lot of things so
that's it becomes this becomes more and
more complicated so
um you know part of being able to live
in a society where there is free
speeches it's the freedom to be wrong
um and that's important too so there it
is complicated um and I think some
people probably have a highly binary
simplistic view let everything go
through but I think that's fairly
unrealistic and also unappealing to most
people again you know so
for me
um I I view my role in this doing what I
did which was I know a lot about this
topic I have access to internal files at
Twitter let me actually bring this to
light for people so they can see what
actually happened these different
mechanisms I was explaining by how these
things were done there's a lot more
granular details but that in a nutshell
and then that starts a conversation
that's the start so I
it indeed I feel like I would be an
to be you know pronoun making
pronouncements about well here's how
everything should run yeah you know so I
don't even feel comfortable saying that
you can tell you know we're all sort of
saying we know what happened was wrong
we know the line should be somewhere
else or maybe a lot maybe that's not
even the right metaphor maybe it's not a
line but it's like a zigzag who knows
what it's a levy over the we can come up
with different metaphors but we don't
know exactly but for my role was let me
just report on this and let's start a
conversation yeah and the idea that that
this is quote like a nothing Burger as
all these people were saying is so
idiotic to me and so like
phony like bogus naive like everything
about that was wrong I mean I I know the
last time I looked like my thread that I
did on Twitter for this for my Twitter
files that I did
um I mean it had more than 60 million
views
and as far as I'm aware
no one covered it in any sort of like
Legacy Media that was shocking to me and
some so my view on this is
even if
and they would be wrong to say this but
even if someone said well what was
reported on here isn't important even if
they thought that the mere fact that
something had 60 million views on it
hundreds of thousands of likes or
whatever the you know whatever the
statistics were that in and of itself
makes it newsworthy I mean that is the
definition of news when something is of
great interest to an enormous number of
people particularly on a topic like this
that is news in and of itself even if
they felt like the content wasn't
important so that is something that as a
society or that people in media I think
need to reckon with it is just a
remarkable
comment on on like the environment we're
in today the culture that something a
thread you know and this isn't about me
I mean Matt taibi is reporting that
their stuff was far more I'll give you
an example hasn't been covered how is it
possible that this stuff was basically
ignored that is remarkable I'll give you
an example we had it in the UK and I
mentioned it at the time the BBC on the
day that the first several instances of
the Twitter files were released they had
a story about uh Elon Musk firing
cleaners who happen to be two women of
color
uh and they had a story uh which was it
wasn't a story it was like a piece which
is who is the billionaire who's who's
running Twitter Elon Musk so they
obviously felt that Twitter and Elon
Musk were important and significant
right but they didn't cover the Twitter
files at all and that to me that was
very telling
um but the other thing I wanted to ask
you about and this is obviously
something that a lot of people felt on
along political lines prior to the
pandemic and then during the pandemic it
I think strengthened how people felt in
this way about it which was
you know Twitter as a company
headquartered in California we all know
that California the values of people in
California are not necessarily
representative of the entire country or
indeed the West more broadly which is
where this conversation was playing
itself out
did you find did as you were reading
this did you feel that this was a group
of people who were almost captured by a
particular worldview or just forget
capture that's a loaded term who held a
particular world view and as a result of
that they were making decisions that
were not necessarily reflective of the
world view shared across the country
a hundred percent
um by there were exceptions and like I
said I saw a lot of robust exchanges
within Twitter amongst employees but by
and large absolutely I mean again the
fact that they went with well here's
what the CDC says that's the truth I
mean that's crazy that you can't
function in a society where a government
agency is the truth and and everything
else is considered misleading or
disinformation
um and
all these people not all most of them
and and this is a known thing are left
meaning
um for lack of a better term and because
the pandemic in America
um was so politicized
um you were on one team or another I
found myself you know sort of floating
in space I I had no incentive whatsoever
to align myself with Republicans
necessarily
um for years I had been a Democrat
um Loosely I mean I have a complex as
you guys probably do too a complex range
of opinions on a complex range of of
topics so I I don't align myself for
yourself shocking I try you know which
makes you far right yeah exactly that
means I am a right-winger I mean I
didn't I did an interview with um I
forget who it was with someone who's
like center right and I sent it to a
group this was I don't know a year ago
and I texted with I'm like a group chat
with with like a bunch of old friends of
mine we've known each other for 20 or
more years and one of them wrote back to
me and said are you in the proud boys
now you know that like white white
supremacist group that's like come on
man you know and he was like half joking
um Jew and the proud boys but anyway it
was um
point being it's like if you questioned
any of these things you automatically
were thrown into that camp on the other
team and you know so for me as as
I think I'm considered one of the only
journalists or maybe the most prominent
one who was writing for a lot of Legacy
Media Publications that tend to be left
leaning
um but I was writing from a very much
um sort of contrarian Viewpoint not
purposely I wasn't like I'm going to be
the contrarian it was that's where the
facts took me and that's what launched
me on this early on in the spring of
2020 when this all began that I saw
everything that was happening I like
most of my neighbors and everyone around
me oh my God there's this crazy virus
let's let's like you know lock the door
everyone
um but very quickly because of my
professional background and someone I
like reading scientific um journals I
read academic journals I talk to
Scholars and research people all the
time so I have that sort of professional
background doing that and also for
better and For Worse my temperament I'm
always poking holes in things I always
see kind of I'm always skeptical about
things and I very quickly started act
well let me just look and see what the
actual evidence is for this and very
quickly it it took me in a direction
that was different from the direction
that I was supposed to be in and all of
a sudden I found myself like you know
cast out of of the of the boat cast out
of the of the thing with everyone else
that I was quote supposed to be with
even though there was no I had zero
political incentive for this I'm not so
but nevertheless I was branded that way
you know I'm I'm a right winger what are
you talking about you know I was
a Bernie supporter years ago so this
this
incredibly infantile
um binary approach to life is just so uh
tiresome and problematic but what I've
come to believe is that I think that's
just how and this is perhaps the
observation but that's just how Society
operates most people people want to be
in a certain tribe and their default is
like in group out group and so I spend a
lot of time writing about this and
digging into this in my book that I'm
working on about this I just it's it's
incredibly fascinating to me I you know
what I know about both of you guys I
think we're in the same we are in our
own little kids that's like the Venn
diagram we're in like this tiny I don't
know how large is our group I don't know
not that we all share the same opinion
but our group of people who are sort of
like not I think there's something do
you think there's something in your
personalities because I think I wonder
this about myself is there something
about us and people like us that we seem
to have less allegiance to groups than
it seems other people do do you think
there's something like well for me we
end up where we ended up for me it's
quite easy because growing up in the
Soviet Union I kind of had a very early
experience of like just because everyone
says everyone goes along with something
doesn't mean it's true and then it's
very like informative yeah and and then
it was replicated more generally I mean
if you if you're
an intelligent kid you look around at
the adults and you realize that people
don't don't have a clue what's
going on right so that from a young age
I realized I'm gonna have to think about
things for myself you know but I
actually you know I think it can be very
dispiriting uh because online
communication makes it feel like we are
one of a handful and then there's the
crazy people on the right and the crazy
people on the left but I think what we
forget
and look the success of our show is kind
of reinforcement of this is there's a
hell of a lot of people in the middle
who are never going to leave a YouTube
comment who don't have a Twitter account
who just want to hear something because
they are in the middle they're trying to
make up their mind they're they're they
they're not hard line and because of
that you don't see them they don't show
up right and there are crucial points in
in the sort of trajectory of society one
yes you have to go in in the voting
booth and you have to pick red or blue
but most of the time I think most people
aren't really that welded to those
political ideologies and you don't see
them as much because they're not on
Twitter screaming because they're trying
to get their kid to school and put food
on the table and whatever so at least
our hope is certainly mine anyway is
we've always tried to speak to those
people and stay away from the crazies on
both sides who are you're right at this
point shaping the debate no question
about it you I think you put this far
better than I did I think you're right
exactly
I should be the guest smash that like
button
oh subscribe good point you're right
because I observed so many times but I
guess what worries me about that a
little bit is and again maybe this is
just human nature Society most people
are either disinterested or disinclined
to speak up so I think you're both
correct that there is a larger number of
people like us than there are but
because most people for whatever
combination of reasons don't say and
I've witnessed this myself am I in my
small town that that I live in with my
kids when the schools were closed there
was this kind of very loud group of
people on the local parents Facebook
group you know and I was called a
murderer for saying that I thought
schools should open even though kids
were in school in Europe at this point
this you know why do you want to murder
children I'll never forget that someone
responded to me that way
um and I'm like you're aware there are
millions of children in school elsewhere
and they're all they're fine I think
there are there still kids in Europe
they're still there yeah
so that's the thing that there's sort of
this dual Dynamic there's both a lot of
us perhaps but for for whatever reason
and maybe a lot of those reasons are
good those sometimes it makes sense why
someone can't speak out for any number
maybe their job they're afraid it's it's
regrettable
um I wish more people were a little more
vocal or involved than if they didn't
because the forces particularly and I
guess I have believe me I have no
shortage of of condemnation for people
on the far right
but I'm far more sensitive about the
left for two reasons one is that I think
I I used to associate myself with the
left for most of my adult life so I have
like a greater
sense of betrayal I feel
um in the way I feel like some of these
people behave during the pandemic so
that's number one number two by and
large the left controls the major levers
of society yes the the politicians in
Washington or in different state houses
or whatever change you know at each
election cycle and but
technology
the movie industry media publishing
fashion so many major pillars of our
society the cultural sort of
cornerstones are far dominated by the
left so that's why I have like a
particular sensitivity of when the left
by and large moves in a certain
direction why that really needs to be
kept in check so much let's dive into
the media a second because we're talking
about journalism here and if you think
about movies there was always the
archetype or the Intrepid journalist
going where others fears to trade in
order to get the story for example if
you look at superheroes I don't think
it's an accident that Peter Parker
Spider-Man is a photojournalist and
Superman is a journalist they were the
ones challenging Authority when did that
stop when did we we start seeing being a
journalist as someone to basically
uphold what the government say
one of the things that like blew my mind
at the beginning of the pandemic
announced what went on was that
um I kept thinking and I've written a
number of pieces that
I I believe it's fair to say that I kind
of blew something open in this sort of
Legacy Media that that wasn't being
talked about whether I was wrote very
early on the very beginning of May
saying we should be opening schools
here's why here's a long compendium of
data to show why this is a good idea
um I there's this in I don't think this
was common in in in Britain or elsewhere
but we had this hybrid schooling model
here where kids go to school for one or
two days a week and they stayed home
and
I was the first person to write a big
piece on this and I had a number of
experts in in the article saying like
this is completely idiotic on for
multiple reasons there's no evidence
that this is going to reduce
transmission so I wrote that there was a
piece that I wrote questioning the CDC
had guidance I'm going to get to my
point in one second the CDC had um
guidance before
um the summer camp guidance where they
wanted children to wear masks outdoors
and when I saw that the guidance came
out I'm like this is nuts so I
immediately I reached out to some really
prominent people in the field uh Dimitri
kristakis is the editor-in-chief of Jama
Pediatrics you know the foremost
pediatric medical journal at a
immunologist at Columbia University
Hospital these people and I reached out
to them I said am I crazy or is this
like completely insane and and they were
like oh this is this is horrible and it
and but and I had a handful of other
pieces on myocarditis I interviewed the
guy um the Israeli scientist who wrote
basically released the first major
report
um I don't even know how I got a hold of
him but I'm there I am texting with this
guy on WhatsApp and we're you know put
so there was a bunch of instances where
I wrote about things that I hadn't seen
exposed yet also the hospitalizations
sorry so now I'm just take your time
this is what we do so okay
I mentioned this not as an
aggrandizement but to a larger Point
than I'm about it is brilliant yes I
mean he's so good yeah so not
but the hot people have been murmuring
for quite a while that you know maybe
this hospitalization numbers aren't
actually reflective of people who are in
the hospital it rather it's with covid
rather than from covid now this also uh
ties into our conversation about the
suppression and censorship on Twitter
and Elsewhere for a long time that was
considered a conspiracy theory and
you're crazy well it turns out that's
true and and and I reported on
um these two studies that were done on
pediatric Admissions and at the time at
least 40 of the Pediatric coveted
emissions were unrelated to covet a kid
maybe they broke their foot or something
and they had to test them for covid and
they just incidentally had covid but it
had nothing to do with why they were in
the hospital but nevertheless that was
added to the tally just very quickly I
had to I had a joke that I tweeted
during the pandemic I said my my
grandfather died with his wife by his
side but it was the middle of the
pandemic so they decided he died of her
and and put her in prison anyway exactly
it was absurd so but if you but people
said this were conspiracy theorists yeah
you're some but it was true so
anyway so the reason I mention all of
these things the school closures the
hybrid the
myocarditis and then a handful of other
things
over and over I kept thinking I I need
to like get this thing out I got part of
being a journalist I generally like a
slow moving on Less in the news cycle
but because I found myself in this you
want to be first I'm like this is
exciting and each time I'd be in a panic
because you know I turned an article at
first I pitch an article to to an editor
then if they accept it then there's you
know then I'm writing and I'm
researching yeah you know the editors go
back it could take a week or two weeks
or longer before you finally put the
thing out depending how in depth it is
and I every I just be nervous waiting
that someone else is going to scoop me
and no one did any of those times and
slowly I started seeing this pattern and
that's the thing this is a very long
response to your to your prompt about
where's the Intrepid reporter and I'm
not saying I am the embodiment of that
but what I would say is there was an
absence of that elsewhere when I wrote
that thing about the um
summer camp guidance I think a day or
two before my piece came out there was a
thing in the New York Times on it and it
was like the nukes you know CDC guidance
for camps is out here's how to keep your
kids safe and it just unquestioningly
they had one or two you know doctors who
talked about it no one questioned the
the
um the validity of any of these
recommendations including making a kid
wear a mask while they're going to be
playing tennis with someone you know uh
30 feet away on the other side of a net
no it wasn't questioned so it's this
idea of like a drone is a journalist
just like a megaphone you know maybe in
some instances instances that's
appropriate but by and large that's what
these people were doing and I was kind
of astonished that over and over it
seemed like these
large media operations with millions or
hundreds of millions of dollars behind
them these are huge institutions with
large staffs of people and editors and
you know this whole operation and they
weren't questioning the guidance they
weren't questioning what was said they
were simply reporting it and they had
the same crew of experts oftentimes and
I use experts in quotes because
oftentimes this is someone like there is
a particular emergency room physician
who who I think was at Brown at the time
um who was quoted constantly in the New
York Times and CNN and these other
places
this person had no expertise on
infectious diseases had no expertise on
on mitigation measures and their
effectiveness nevertheless this person
was quoted they're on like the speed
dial
um at a place like the New York Times
um so you had no questions asked of
fauci or CDC and then when there was
certain questions asked it was almost
always from the same pool of of of of
quote experts who were basically just
supporting what was being said anyway so
that's that was the weird thing for me I
just was now when I look back it's funny
but you can imagine me I was so nervous
I was going to get scooped on each of
these things someone surely is going to
write a piece in some major place about
like why our schools aren't open here
when they're open everywhere else and
I'm like no one wrote that someone
shortly is going to write about the
hospitalizations someone all these
things and it wasn't happening so it's
just been it was just a bizarre
experience that I will ever get over
like it's permanently altered me
um seeing this you know from my own
experience as a writer um in that
environment and it's also has
repercussions right the way down the
line because we've all agreed that the
media weren't being honest about covert
the mainstream media weren't being
honest I think that's that's fair to say
and then they report on Ukraine and
everybody goes well how can I trust you
and then you get a large portion of
people coming out and going well they
weren't honest about covid AKA they're
not going to be honest about this I
don't believe it and then what you have
is a fundamental breakdown between media
and the people and that's a really
dangerous place to be in I mean I think
there's a couple things there journalism
in my view should be adversarial to
Authority and and for whatever complex
range of reasons
um
that you know we could go into but it's
again writing a thousand pages on on the
on the why but for a long range of
reasons that sort of skepticism of of
Institutions
um was
absent it vaporized we like big Pharma
now right exactly I mean these are the
these are the things that traditionally
doesn't make any sense
they used to in the left traditionally
was like yeah exactly it was like highly
skeptical of these places like big
Pharma the government you know these but
because I think because it's so
politicized they then just threw their
hat in with this group that's one piece
of it I don't think it's the only piece
um that that and then the public ends up
not trusting it because they are at
least a a large section segment of the
public and I think one of the things
that's funny not to get too far afield
here but and if I'm not already canceled
maybe this will cancel me but like
excellent but here we go
um is that there's so much talk about
diversity which is important you know
for racial diversity and other types but
we don't see and again this is an
observation many people there's not an
ideological diversity in a lot of these
institutions and like most of the people
who work at these you know at the times
or are you know these major TV networks
these are I mean I know a lot of these
people personally and I know of they all
went to Yale and brown and Colombia and
Harvard they all went to the same places
they're all there inside there imagine
at the Times instead of their diversity
lens instead if it was trained on well
let's let's hire some people who just
went to some Community College let's go
and let's get someone who grew up in in
West Virginia and maybe didn't go to
college at all but it's like real smart
and has some sort of grit imagine how
different the coverage would be of all
sorts of issues whether it's related to
the pandemic or otherwise so although
there's certain types of diversity but
you're missing out on on Working Class
People you know journalism used to be
more of a working class kind of
profession at one point in certain
regards you know you know a number of
generations ago now it's it's far more
um I think elitist so these people and
and I think that there's a wonderful
article I think it's Thomas Frank from
years ago in Harpers
um and he wrote about how
um Bernie Sanders and he was running
basically was murdered by the his
campaign
um by the mainstream media and and he
roughly says this and this is some of my
own sort of projection onto his thesis
but
in order to get into a place like Yale
or brown how do you get in there well
you're a certain type of person who
follows rules maybe some people get in
there who are iconoclasts they're just
brilliant but most of the people you're
getting in there because you're an apple
polisher you're the worker bee you know
how to get straight A's you know 4.0
grade average you're a perfect student
and then you get in there and you're you
know how to work your way within an
institution and network and you get
perfect grades there and then maybe you
go to Columbia journalism school and you
follow this path so there the way that
these people became successful was
through a certain path that's their life
that's their lubed experience is is
doing this so it makes sense so then
they saw Bernie as this Outsider how
could this guy win or who dare he you
know how should he do this you know he's
not one of us and I think
and I think we also see that in coverage
of a whole range of issues including
with the pandemic that if you have all
these people who all know each other
they all have the same kind of
background the same way that they became
successful
um that to to Veer from that I'm not
even saying this is a conscious thing I
think it's just like it makes sense this
is just how they view things so that
that's my that's my thesis on on that
and we haven't even reached as far as
I'm concerned the real punch line of the
pandemic which is the effect on
children's education and attainment and
also as well what that is going to be
doing to the ever widening gap between
attainment between rich kids and poor
kids
right well you know and there's
um my focus on reporting has not been on
what people will call sort of like
victim porn on the horrible things that
happen to Children
um because to me it's just like so
self-evident that this was absurd
um but there's so much just obvious
evidence from this this was obvious
before it even happened and now we have
also from the academic harms
um you know from kids that we know that
children who are in less privileged
backgrounds were going to do we knew
this was going to happen I wrote a piece
where the New York Times actually early
on the pandemic about what they call
these pod schools they probably didn't
have this in the UK where
um you would pay what wealthy parents
would pay generally wealthy you know it
could be twenty thousand dollars or a
group of parents got together and they
hired a teacher and they had a pod of
like it could be five kids ten kids were
they because the schools were closed
um so those kids had the money they had
the Pod or they had tutors they have you
know they can get all the sexual help
but some kid who's living in you know a
tiny apartment in the Bronx
um with with eight other people or
whatever the circumstance may be and
there are those kids
um because I've spoken to them and I've
spoken to their parents and their
teachers
they they were never going to learn Jack
um they didn't have an internet
connection there were kids who were
sitting in a parking lot of the Taco
Bell so they could have a Wi-Fi
connection to try to get on to some
remote learning program that is
nuts so for any so the idea because I
was branded a racist as were many other
people who advocated for schools to open
they was considered they said it's
racist to one school soap and it's white
supremacist but the the horrible irony
of course is that the greatest harms
were go we knew this from this could be
seen very easily from the beginning and
it was obvious while it was happening
the greatest harms were born by the kids
who were Brian disproportionately black
or brown
um and certainly moving away from race
just who had less resources regardless
of what your race was we knew
the people who have the money they're
always going to be okay most of them I
mean those kids suffer too make no
mistake a lot of them everyone's
different and it's not automatically
you're going to do horribly if you don't
have money but that's the broad Trend
and this was of course obvious so school
is more than just a place for learning
math or something and particularly for
younger kids in America school has a
role of of a societal function where
there are people by the way were
dismissed and maligned for saying oh you
you just want to babysitter up it's a
bunch of parents just want babysitters
for their kids well that's that should
not be put down like care for children
is really important and that's a
wonderful function of school that's not
something that should have been like
dismissed it's like you're an
for wanting your you know six-year-old
to go to a place while you're going to
work like but somehow these people were
branded as selfish it's the sort of
thing you say when you've got your own
babysitter
and that's where it comes from but I
know you've got a book about this coming
out so uh we'll tell everybody when it's
coming out and what it's going to be
called well it's called an abundance of
caution
um
at least in the states I feel like they
did in the UK too this phrase was
constantly used out of an abundance of
caution dot dot dot and I remember when
they closed my kids schools that the
email was sent out and there it was out
of an abundance of caution we need to
close schools for a deep cleaning they
said you know nothing but um so that
phrase always stuck in my head because
the question is well caution in what
direction
[Music]
and what we what I spend a lot of time
writing about and God knows when the
book's going to come out because I'm
still working on this house probably not
for a year I saw that when I asked David
there was that little Pang I know
every night like my son he's like Dad
are you still working on that book I'm
like yes stop asking me I'd like my like
temples pulsing but um but you think
about
a lot of these interventions including
school closures I think there's good
evidence that
the most important word that is not
talked about enough about relation to
the pandemic and these interventions is
time and a lot of things can be
effective over a very short period of
time if the a physician puts on a very
tightly fitted n95 respirator and sees a
patient for a 10 minute checkup in a
room that mask may very well be
protective to some extent but that's
different from wearing some
quack mask in a classroom with 20 other
kids for eight hours and similarly you
know pulling the master switch and
keeping everyone home for a week or two
weeks or not everyone but the people who
can stay home that can definitely have
an effect I think there's good evidence
the problem is
a pandemic's a marathon it's not going
to end and you know quickly and over
time we know that people's ability to
comply with things Lanes you just
wearing a mask is annoying for
most people
um it's not natural and whether you
purposely don't want to do it or you're
just like even subconsciously you're
tugging at it people are rubbing their
eyes they've done studies on this you
can see people constantly touching their
face or whether it's something like
school closures people are going to
spread their ability and there's Google
Mobility data for this too you could see
people just started moving around more
and more as time went on and you saw
this happen even in places where the
restrictions were still in place that
that didn't stop it that you can't like
Hammer people with this stuff human
beings most of them are not comfortable
being completely isolated from each
other they can't do it and so what
happens is this this confusion about
well this works or that doesn't work of
course if people don't go to school
there'll be less transmission well yeah
maybe for a week or two but over a month
or two months or three months and that's
the main misconception I think that a
lot of people have about these
interventions that yes I'm not someone
who says masks don't work or this quote
doesn't work that's that's too
simplistic of a way of framing these
things it's some things may work to some
extent in this particular circumstance
for a certain period of time it's not a
sexy answer it's not as easy to just
tweet that but that's the truth the
things that you need all these little
qualifiers so we knew that over time
this stuff was simply not going to be
effective and and that's what I believe
the evidence shows well I was going to
wrap up that but just maybe one more
thing on that I think one of the things
that you touched on that but I think we
could expand on a little bit is that too
many people forget that safety isn't
deal only thing that we are ever
pursuing I mean freedom for this country
would not exist if people didn't get
together who valued something other than
safety above safety right the the United
States was created by a bunch of people
who put themselves In Harm's Way
that is the very definition of being the
opposite of safety for something else
right that something else is called
freedom in their case right so the one
of the reasons I think we're stuck in
the place that we're stuck in is that
people have forgotten that safety is not
the only value
it's not the only thing that we care
about and we cannot care about otherwise
we'd never leave the house now I would
say two things one agree with you 100 on
that that you know there's a reason why
we right people go swimming even though
a certain number of people drown every
year swimming we get in a car we do
everything if you the second you step
out of your house there's some degree of
danger depending what you're going to do
but that's part of life including we
also endanger other people because the
argument against what you're saying
people say well that's different that's
you just endangering yourself but with
the virus you're endangering other
people well guess what every time you
get in a car you're endangering other
people too but we all choose to partake
in that and we don't force everyone to
drive 10 miles an hour so there's a
whole range of things we do where we are
endangering each other and we accept
that as a society because we value these
other things for human flourishing
Beyond just putting ourselves in bubble
wrap but the other thing is
staying home is not safe either over
time and that's the other flip side
again about this idea of caution that
it's like well there are people and I
wrote this piece about this church that
um gotten a huge lawsuit with a county
in California
um where they were bar all churches
there were barred from having anyone
gather indoors for many many many months
and and so they this church ignored the
guidelines people got together anyway
and they accrued an extraordinary number
of fines it's an it's an amazing Story I
mean they were spied on they they had
they were that they were special Health
officers peering at them through a
chain-length fence they were right and
they were going into the church and
monitoring private activities it was
it's an insane story but but the the
message from it though is to your point
is
a lot of the people I interviewed these
were people from from the church church
members these were people and by the way
I don't attend church I had no skin in
the game about sport but these are
people suffering from addiction
um elderly people who were profoundly
lonely there was a guy who I think there
were more than one I spoke to one myself
who wanted to commit suicide because he
was so profoundly lonely he had gone
through a breakup and for these people
church was their support system is it
mine no but I have to understand and
respect for them they needed
so the idea that they're safe because
they're kept home was these
people some of them were literally at
risk of dying themselves and we know
that there's epigenetics with when you
how your environment affects your immune
system it is telling a bunch of people
you need to be isolated particularly
elderly people oh you're in an old age
home and your family can't visit you
like of course that has a profound
effect on people's underlying health so
we're seeing this and it's very
complicated but with excess death rates
and all sorts of other measures about
what makes for a good life so you know
to your point this sort of like myopic
focus on a virus
and not looking at all these other
aspects of what makes for a flourishing
life
um again maybe that made sense for a
couple weeks in the beginning but very
quickly that you know the ratio changes
about what is reasonable
um both from a public health standpoint
and also a mental health standpoint so
that's how I view it it's been a
fantastic interview thank you so so much
for coming on the show the final
question we always our school I guess is
um are you vaccinated
[Laughter]
because if you're not you're killing
people
You're a murderer and um murdering kids
anyway it's what's the one thing we're
not talking about as a society that we
really should be
I
I would say just moving away from this
topic one thing that has long interested
me is
um everyone talks about climate change
um as this macro concern and I'm not I'm
not even going to touch on the validity
of this but one thing that I think is
really important for people who care
about the environment and and I'm
someone who's long cared about the
environment very much is
climate change is a very abstract idea
but there are very concrete things that
are happening to our planet and to
animals that that we actually can stop
because it seems like we failed at
climate change every year they have the
meetings they go to you know Davos or
the you know Kyoto wherever else and
they talk about it but like we still
keep producing like this isn't working
but once you have stolen my dreams right
exactly but the thing we can do is you
know there are
an enormous number of sharks that are
killed every year so people can have
soup with their fin are you
kidding me and they slice the fin off
this majestic animal and they just toss
them back in the ocean and they're left
there to just slowly bleed out and die
um and they don't even use the rest yeah
so shark fin soup where you think about
um there are still multiple countries
that do commercial whaling I think I
might be wrong but I think it's like
Iceland Norway
um Japan that is insane to my view
um and you and palm oil I'll stop here
with you know most of the garbage that
we eat you know all these processed
foods they have palm oil in them that is
a massive
um source of deforestation they burn or
chop down incredibly important and Rich
um rainforests and other really old
growth forests and put up a bunch of you
know palm trees from making palm oil
that is horrible for the species that
used to live there who are now dead
because they don't have a home horrible
for Greenhouse so those are the things
that I think get lost once it's you know
once again it's easy to just be like we
need to help stop climate change well
guess what that messaging failed it
doesn't seem to work because we still
keep producing all the stuff so instead
I would love for people to focus more on
how do we save specific animals how do
we stop specific practices that to my
mind are completely unacceptable and in
50 years from now we will be embarrassed
that these things were happening from
factory farms to the shark fins Etc
that's what people should talk about
absolutely David thank you so much for
coming on the show uh really looking
forward to reading your upcoming book of
course you have this one as well which
we didn't get to talk about this book
everybody buy this book uh everybody and
we're going to head over to locals for
your bonus questions so join us there uh
all the links for David's work are in
the description uh take care we'll see
you on locals very shortly
does David think the reason Twitter
agreed to sense the information was due
to your willing alliance with the
government out of fear of the government
if it didn't comply why are ideological
conviction that censoring certain voices
was correct